[Music]
the following program contains the
opinions of its host and guests not
those of this network the opinions
expressed are for non-commercial
informational purposes only listeners
are cautioned not to rely on program
content to treat or prevent disease but
are advised to consult with a licensed
health care professional where they live
for diagnosis and treatment of disease
and now the superstar of alternative
health and purveyor of medical truth dr.
Joel Wallach
[Music]
hello and welcome to dead doctors don't
lie dr. Joel Wallach your host a
veterinarian in position and I'm here
for kids and baby mores and teen years
who don't want 75.5 like their parents
or grandparents I'm here for kids and
baby boomers and seniors who don't wanna
be sick and miserable the last 15 or 20
years of the life like their parents and
grandparents and of course I achieved
the rank of lieutenant colonel in the
Air Force and a lot of people say I
treat them like dogs but they do seem to
get better now we have a personal health
challenge when asked about if you have a
health shown you a friend a workmate all
right want to talk about medical
politics or the home-based business
opportunity give us a call toll free one
triple eight three seven nine two five
five two again that's toll-free one
five two I want to talk a little bit
today about youngevity and the business
aspect that we're growing so rapidly we
need some more help we have literally
thousands of products things close to
5,000 products and we're primarily a
health and beauty company okay and we do
have sports things and fertilizers for
gardens which I had tribute to good
health and so forth and youngevity
business is a willable asset your
youngevity business is a willable asset
and like any other business you have to
use tools so that everybody who's
involved in your organization your
personal organization and the company's
organization will be giving the same
answers the same programs for the same
questions okay if everybody's left to
their own devices to figure out what to
do it'll be chaos and failure so we came
up with a group of tools we have CDs
DVDs and nine languages we have books we
have 14 different books we're excited
about that we have a documentary which
has a subtitle you can actually push a
button and determine if you want to
watch it in Spanish or French or Chinese
or Japanese or whatever okay and then of
course you need to have a weekly meeting
you can pick today a weekly meeting so
the people who are in your sort of
immediate era can go to you and you're
going to teach for people in your
organization or in other cities in other
states do the same thing
so you'll have the organization you'll
have a meeting on Monday nice and
Tuesday nights and Wednesday night and
Thursday nights and Friday night
Saturday afternoon and Sunday after
church and so on because all these
different places will pick different
days to have their weekly meetings
then you need a monthly meeting used to
call them super Saturday's and this is
where all of these groups say from a
region you know the mountains of States
or the south west or the Gulf states
would get together and come to these
events and make it be sort of the same
play the same time and you get different
leaders to speak either on the business
for the products okay and then of course
you have an annual meeting of course the
company has an annual meeting and
different locations and things and we
give awards and so on but you need to
have an annual meeting - I like peoples
also holidays in people's birthdays or
the fourth of July and you know various
holidays and so forth and to make all
this work again you need information and
part of the tool system would be the
trilogy of books let's play doctor let's
play herbal doctor passport they've been
learning their deal with over 900
different diseases using vitamins and
minerals and trace minerals and rare
earths amino acids fatty is as herbs
aromatherapy oils and don't forget our
spray and our foam Santa hand sanitizer
okay then we have toothpastes you know
for dental health and we have a bar soap
and we have laundry soap and all this
stuff
and shampoos and non-toxic beauty
products and skincare and so on okay and
then of course we have the documentary
which I said we have the dead doctors
don't live books and CDs and DVDs we
have the rare earths material attached
on how to collect the hair and where to
send it and to three weeks at the
results and teach you how to interpret
results so you can really make a a
supplement program that exceeds anything
that a medical doctor to do you also
want to get a hold of the book in
mortality and the CD immortality forever
young and learn what it is why do the
top 20 you learn Judy cultures on earth
according to National Geographic have 40
times 100 olds we Americans do you have
100 over 250 that our population we only
have one per 10,000 and so the
the things you need to know and if you
want to be a farmer if you want to grow
some of your own food they know it's
non-gmo and non gluten and non-toxic
doesn't have any sprays and things on
I'm gonna get these half barrels and put
them on your balcony in your
parliamentary or your back porch here
house and then of course we have the
fertilizer called
bloomin it's like blooming with the G
job to have bloom and minerals and the
bloom and minerals has 78 minerals in it
and we grow 15-pound sweet potatoes we
go
one pound tomatoes we grow two to three
pound lemons we grow five to eight pound
beets and so forth with this fertilizer
and of course you can grow many many
things with this fertilizer comes in
granules and in court sizes and also in
forty pound bags we also have the liquid
okay in quarts and gallons and 55-gallon
drums and so these are things that you
can do on your own and we're talking
about tomatoes and bell peppers and
sweet potatoes and scallions and so on
and these are things you can actually
give some fresh food that you're
involved with you're connected with the
earth and you're gonna know that these
things are safe okay do we know more
about this and how it works and
everything get a hold of that book rare
earths ventures it's kind of like a
Farmers Almanac on a high grade scale
very very high in information rare earth
oven cures and of course we have some of
the results of this and one of the DVDs
is called praise the Lord and pass the
ninety is to take off in a first world
war prayer praise the Lord and pass the
ammunition and we have so many things
for different groups of people athletes
the black community seniors women men
children and so on and you have these
tools that are built for those different
communities it makes your life easier no
matter which communities you're gonna
work with and it gets very exciting so I
urge you to contact your young to be
associate say hey I'm really really
really wanting to be involved in young
giving and
count me in we'll be back with dead
doctors don't lie after these messages
you're listening to dead doctors don't
lie on the CBS radio network with your
host dr. Joel Wallach if you'd like to
talk to dr. Wallach call us on the
priority line eight three one six eight
five one zero eight zero toll-free 888
three seven nine 255 two
[Music]
if you're looking for a quality
multivitamin and mineral product grab
yourself youngevity beyond tangy
tangerine a blend of plant derived
minerals combined with vitamins amino
acids and other beneficial nutrients
this all-natural product contains no
starch wheat or yeast with no artificial
sweeteners or preservatives and its
glycemic friendly each scoop of the
Nutri crystals contain equal amounts of
all the nutrients it starts out as a
liquid then it's freeze-dried to ensure
each scoop has the same nutrients as the
last scoop so if you want to get your
hands on a quality nutritional
supplement designed to give the body the
raw materials it needs to rebuild
youngevity is beyond tangy tangerine is
available in one-pound canisters and
also in 30 count on the go stick packs
contact your local youngevity associate
and get this great multivitamin and
mineral product and don't forget to ask
about the home-based business
opportunity in recent years several
studies have discovered the healthy
benefits of drinking coffee youngevity
has now taken it a step further with an
entire product line of healthy coffees
from youngevity x' java fit light of top
shelf gourmet coffees all java fit
coffees are made from 100% hand-selected
a rack of a coffee beans grown in the
finest regions of Latin America all
carefully roasted creating a delicious
rich full-bodied flavor try Java fit
focus plus multivitamins a fantastically
delicious full-bodied gourmet coffee
that is fortified with vitamins and
minerals designed to get your day
started with a solid nutritional
foundation traditional as well as
organic and fair trade options also
available in 30 Cal single cup or 24
count single pot packs contact your
local FDI youngevity distributor to get
Java luciene coffees and don't forget to
ask about home-based business
opportunities
[Music]
we're back again doctors don't lie on
the CBS rating Network dr. Joel log here
if you didn't night doctors say and we
do have lines open musical toll-free one
triple eight three seven nine two five
five two again that's toll-free one
times two again if you're gonna do the
youngevity business as a business you
want to get a hold of that silly to you
books let's play dr. let's play herbal
doctor Hasbro chromotherapy in the CDs
and DVDs of documentaries and so forth
and you want to give get the samples we
have samples you can hand out and as you
have your meetings and things are your
speaking 101 or somebody else's house
and they've had neighbors come over you
show the DVD on their TV and so forth
but we remember youngevity is a willable
has said you can be profitable you can
teach these people how to get their
products or wholesale so they're going
to be concerned about paying retail all
that kind of stuff okay and in their
business plan they can have their
youngevity business pay for their own
products and give it to them as a
benefit just like you know big
corporations give benefits to their
employees and so they can actually get
the products for free that way and their
youngevity business well will actually
get the tax deductions for giving out
these samples and it's really really
very exciting when you think about it
and do we deal with over 900 different
diseases and so you have a wide wide
wide scope of people can help when it
comes down to people who do exercise or
play sports don't forget her
a rebound our wonderful wonderful sports
drink with 100 nutrients in it
Wow and you'll be able to help your kids
and grandkids your spouse yourself your
neighbor your cash for anybody who
exercises or plays sports okay Doug yeah
what pearls wisdom you here for well I
thought we'd talk about a natural news
story headlined six foods you thought
were healthy but aren't so here are six
foods many people think are healthy but
they actually aren't agave nectar of
derived from the agave plant is marketed
as a healthy alternative to sugar
and is suitable for people with diabetes
however these claims aren't true agave
nectar does not cause the same blood
sugar spikes as table sugar because it
contains some mostly fructose however
excess fructose may put on a stress on
your body as such as your liver liver
processes for fructose eating high
fructose foods put some extra work on
the organ to convert these sugars into
fat as a result it you may add to body
fat percentage and lead to other health
problems may also increase the risk of
cardiovascular disease metabolic
syndrome and type 2 diabetes and number
2 bottled and store-bought fruit juices
and smoothies bottled in store-bought
smoothies and fruit juices are highly
processed therefore they're unhealthy
processing strips the fruit of almost
all vitamin C and other nutrients like
in fiber and calcium may also increase
diabetes risk because it contain
artificial sugars and diet sodas diet
sodas still contain artificial
sweeteners such as aspartame which are
harmful to human health may cause
irritable moods and depression according
to a study published in the journal
research in in Nursing and Health
instant oatmeal not only does it have
gluten but it's also contains fibers
oats do kin and proteins vitamins and
minerals however instant oatmeal on the
other hand the nutrients because of the
processing has been taken out instant
oatmeal's also contain additional
flavorings such as flour and added
sugars heavily processed breads yeah
they go on to say many breads are highly
processed in the bran and germ are
stripped from the bread for a smooth
texture also increases the breads
glycemic load and candied up trail mixes
store-bought trail mixes contain added
ingredients like chocolate bits and
yogurt covered fruits salt sugar and
additional oils and which can add plenty
of calories to an already Calvery rich
snack so there you go some of those are
ones you've been promoting against for
years oh absolutely
and of course what was true 50 years ago
was still true today and so these are
the sort of things that people if
they're gonna work with us either
as a customer or an associate or a
business builder they really really need
to get information so that we're all
telling the same information when people
ask the question well so-and-so said
that this is a good firm they want me to
use oils well I know they got that
information because oil is what causes
plaque in your arteries not cholesterol
clothes toys you guys friend my doctor
my cardiologist said it can't have
cholesterol we need to flee from that
cardiologist because either doesn't know
what he's talking about or he's just
trying to get you sick sit and do some
stints in your heart okay
and so these are things you have to
watch of course Doug did a great on
coffee and weight loss yesterday believe
it was and so you want to look into our
Jean Lafitte coffee oh my gosh
greatest coffee in the market we owned
the plantations in Nicaragua we actually
fertilize it with our youngevity
blooming minerals so our coffee has oh
yeah 78 minerals in it we'll be back
after these messages you're listening to
dead doctors don't lie on the CBS radio
network with your host dr. Joel Wallach
if you'd like to talk to dr. Wallach
call between noon and 1:00 Pacific at
eight three one six eight five one zero
eight zero toll-free 888 three seven
nine two five five two
if weight loss is your goal try
youngevity slender FX keto caramel
weight management bars and shake
designed to enhance any low carbohydrate
or low glycemic diet by supplying the
energizing and filling protein dieters
need without unhealthy excess carbs a
keto diet known for its low carb intake
pushing the body to produce ketones from
fat used as energy a state known as
ketosis by using fat not carbohydrates
as fuel in this metabolic state a keto
diet supports and promotes healthy
weight management for optimal health
with this system you should be able to
lose 1 to 2 pounds each day so what are
you waiting for start helping people
today with your own home-based business
hey if you're like me your life is
hectic
you don't know where you're gonna be
next between kids and family and in-laws
and work and traffic and everything else
that's driving me crazy right now my
life is insane I bet your wife's insane
as well when do we have time to get
every single nutrient we need to be
healthy when well I've got a tip for you
take a product called pollen burst it's
so simple even I can do it all you have
to do is open the package pour it in
water mix it up and bam you're ready to
go it tastes great it's not one of those
medicine tasting things it tastes great
low in calories helps curb your appetite
gives you natural energy that doesn't
let you crash gives you your vitamins
minerals nutrients everything from the
plant world and I gotta tell you for a
busy person like me or a busy person
like you we need simple we need good
poem verses your answer tastes great try
it and you'll feel better call your
local youngevity distributor to find out
how pollen burst can make you feel
better
ahead don't forget to ask about
home-based business opportunities you've
listed a physician and veterinarian dr.
Joel Wallach helped many people on the
dead doctors don't lie talk radio
program you've also heard hundreds of
people tell how dr. Wallach and
youngevity products have changed their
lives if your
now convinced that dr. Wallach is on to
something and you want to try your
Japanese premium quality products for
yourself we could connect you with a
distributor that serves your local area
simply call our special helpline
voicemail at three one three four four
four 3463
that's three one three four four four
three four six three call right now and
leave your name telephone number or
email address and we'll see to it that
the right person contacts you shortly
remember the phone number three one
three four four four 3463 that's three
one three four four four three four six
three call down to change your life
that's three one three four four four
[Music]
we're back with dead doctors don't lie
on the CBS radio network dr. Joel
Wallach you're giving nice I could say
we do have lines open gifts call
toll-free one two three seven nine to
five to again as total three one Shiva
late three seven nine two five five two
if you want to live me well behind one
hundred chronologically a hundred ten
hundred twenty hundred thirty four
hundred 1,500 1,600 1,700 1,800 ninety
two hundred plus will being biologically
a thirty party fifty contact your young
to be associate and ask for the book
epigenetics the death of the genic there
is a transmission get a hold of the book
immortality and the CD immortality
forever young and learn why according to
National Geographic why the top 20
longevity cultures have 40 times 100 we
do you have 100 over 250 there
population we only have one for 10,000
what are their secrets and then of
course you want to get all the book
rares ventures and learn how to and
there's big chapters on longevity
cultures in there okay and so you want
to then of course go to chapter 11 in
the book rather than cures and learn how
to collect here how to box it up or ship
of two to three weeks you get the
results in I will also tell you how to
actually maximize the benefit of the
information for your adding many
healthier to your life okay Doug let's
go to colors all right let's head to San
Diego California and Maria you're on
with dr. Wallach well Maria you're on
the air okay Anna said you said you had
another episode of what again okay I'm
still missing that Doug can you
understand what she's saying
carpet help heart palpitations okay all
right do you have any diagnosis you have
a diagnosis of atrial fibrillation or
back problems
resolution not better than this
okay back from looking up between your
shoulder blades your neck and their neck
okay yeah well what happens is and how
are you and how much you weigh Maria
[Music]
sixty okay
and how tall are you hi I have two okay
all right yeah um should be shrunken in
height you know we were you five three
one time and you're now down to five -
okay so you shrunk a little bit's not
unusual okay so when you shrink what
happens is the disc little fibrous
cushions between the vertebrae your neck
and your upper back your lower back
shrink and the vertebrae get closer
again they smash the roots of the spinal
nerves control the rate and rhythm of
the heart if you have a fast heart rate
with palpitations your heart beats
irregularly this could be called atrial
fibrillation and this is caused by the
disc from the first four thoracic
vertebra t one two three and four
getting thinner you ever bring it closer
together they smashed roots of the
spinal nerves are controlled rate more
than the heart and so in your situation
need to get rid of the bad foods to
maximize absorption no fried foods
processed meats no deli slices a
sandwich meat sausage ham bacon Bologna
salami pastrami pepperoni jerky that
kind of stuff no seizure no oils no
olive oil coconut oil MC TOS aggressive
cooking oils man that he's got here with
all that and then no gluten the weeper
the right notes no okay so we burn
around host and hangar we'll come back
if your pen a favorite reading I will
give you a program to deal with this
after these messages you're listening to
dead doctors don't lie on the CBS radio
network with your host dr. Joel Wallach
if you'd like to talk to dr. Wallach
call us between noon and 1:00 Pacific at
eight three one six eight five one zero
eight zero
toll-free 888 three seven nine two five
five two
[Music]
you've listed two position add
veterinarian dr. Joel Wallach helped
many people on the dead doctors dov'è
talk radio program you've also heard
hundreds of people tell how dr. Wallach
and youngevity products have changed
their lives if you're now convinced that
dr. Wallach is on to something and you
want to try your Japanese premium
quality products for yourself we could
connect you with the distributor that
serves your local area simply call our
special helpline voicemail at three one
three four four four 3463
that's three one three four four four
three four six three call right now and
leave your name telephone number or
email address and we'll see to it that
the right person contacts you shortly
remember the phone number three one
three four four four 3463 that's three
one three four four four three four six
three call down to change your life
that's three one three four four four
3463 hi this dr. Joel Wallach your host
of dead doctors don't lie if you're
interested in a colon cleanse blood
cleanse liver cleanse in the classical
herbal way you want to ask your
youngevity associate for herbal
rainforest herbal rainforest has 16
herbs 16 cleansing herbs classic
cleansing herbs and 77 plant minerals
that's right and these are all organic
it doesn't get any better than that in
your busy day and you're around all
these toxins out there in your workplace
on the way home going to work in your
food in the air in the water you need
herbal rain plus I guarantee it it will
give you a cleanse you can control the
dose it's a liquid it tastes good it
doesn't get any better than this a colon
that's happy makes you happy
nothing better than a happy : verbal
rainforest clean it up for more
information on this product or others
you've heard about all the dead doctors
don't lie radio program call your local
youngevity associate today and don't
forget to ask about home-based business
opportunities greetings everyone
Judy developers here what do you think
of when you hear the words tangy
tangerine well I think like a sweet
tangy tasting something
well what I'm referring to is the
ultimate tangy tangerine it's a
fantastic product it has everything you
need and a great benefit is it's very
very delicious it's very easy to drink
I've suggested it even to youngsters
even children like it even little guys
even little girls they come right into
my office their parents can't get them
to take those chewables and besides that
they're not as good as tangy tangerine
and I give him a little taste of that
and you know something they're pleased
his punch so if it's good for a child
and it tastes delicious why not you
there's no excuse not to take a vitamin
when it tastes as good as that does so
how about it tangy tangerine should be
the answer to all of your nutritional
program problem for more information or
to order call your youngevity
distributor today and don't forget to
ask about youngevity home-based business
opportunities this is the CBS Radio
Network Network
[Music]
we're back with doctors don't mind the
CBS radio network dr. Joel Wallach here
for youngevity 95 to say we do have
lines open give us a call toll-free one
triple eight three seven nine two five
five two again as toll-free one triple
eight three seven nine two five five two
and if you want to live be well behind
100 chronologically you say 110 120 130
140 hundred 1,500 1,600 1,700 1,800
ninety two hundred plus well being
biologically thirty forty fifty contact
young give me a so ship and as for the
books epigenetics the depth of the genic
3G transmission the book in mark Kennedy
and the book wreckers been cures and
find out why the top 20 longevity
cultures have 40 times 100 we do they
have 100 for 250 population we Americans
only have one for 10,000 what are their
secrets contacts young give you
associate and ask for the books
epigenetics immortality and rarest
ventures and of course get the CDs what
kills or excuse me
dead athletes don't live and what kills
billionaires the CDs okay let's go to
colors let's at Ruttenberg des Moines
Iowa and Marissa
girag with dr. Wallach okay Marissa how
can we help you hi grandmother but the
main reason why I'm calling is I she's
inside doses male-pattern 0 ba okay and
how old is your grandmother 89 okay a 9
years old okay has she had any other
problems she have any other problems
diabetes arthritis
how about pressure I'm just arises in
Cottman rosacea gentle heart failure
diabetes high blood pressures private
myalgia and arthritis
okay he said what kind of heart failure
genital okay congenital okay that's me
she was born with a problem which I'm a
congestive heart failure or congenital
congenital okay
I'm sorry Oh congestive okay that's
that's much different okay okay very
good okay and what does she weigh 156
okay how tall is she
five five okay that's not too bad all
right
okay sharp what's going on with this
grandmother Marisa here she's got
psoriasis she's got rosacea as you got
arthritis he's got an incontinence which
means she can't control her urination
she has a male pattern baldness which is
kind of interesting that's what she's
concerned about has congestive heart
failure yeah well she definitely has a
gluten intolerance because when she
mentioned the rosacea yep so she's
definitely got a gluten intolerance
which caused her to get all these
different things because she's not able
to absorb the nutrients to prevent those
things from going wrong yeah well every
one of them is a nutritional deficiency
right and so what would you give her 156
pounds what sort of diet would you give
her what nutritional program would you
put her on well obviously she needs to
be on a gluten-free diet and I would
give her she's right on the cusp but I'd
get her too healthy brain and heart
packs and if she's concerned about hair
loss she could we have hair skin and
nail she could take that she could take
the immortality for stem cell growth too
you know that the gluco gel 15 a day
there's one two bottles a month five at
breakfast lunch and dinner what would
you do perfect unit eight plus plus plus
kiddo
because congestive heart there is a
deficiency of a single vitamin we've
known that for 300 years there's ask
everybody Japanese naval surgeon and
there's all kinds of herbs and
medications which are based on the
herbal stuff it will control the
symptoms of congestive heart but it'll
never quite go away cause it's a
nutritional deficiency have to give the
nutrients for it to go away and so
exactly correct you get an A plus and so
if you would do these things and I was
going to take maybe five to seven days
working days to get the products were
here
grandmother can actually start the diet
immediately this means absolutely no
fried food no processed meats or
nitrates and nitrites no oils gluten no
sugar and no carbonated drinks even ones
you think of being behind club soda and
ginger ale
[Music]
you've listed a physician and
veterinarian dr. Joel Wallach helped
many people on the dead doctors dov'è
talk radio program you've also heard
hundreds of people tell how dr. Wallach
and youngevity products have changed
their lives if you're now convinced that
dr. Wallach is on to something and you
want to try your Japanese premium
quality products for yourself we could
connect you with a distributor that
serves your local area simply call our
special helpline voicemail at three one
three four four four 3463 that's three
one three four four four three four six
three call right now and leave your name
telephone number or email address and
we'll see to it that the right person
contacts you shortly
remember the phone number three one
three four four four 3463 that's three
one three four four four three four six
three call down to change your life
that's three one three four four four
I am Judy de valois here I am speaking
to you again I just wanted to tell you
that recently I started drinking the way
shakes again the chocolate way shake and
you need to remember the way shake isn't
just for losing weight it's a fantastic
place to get your great protein and if
you're trying to gain weight you can
take it along with your meals and the
best part is if you want to just have a
great protein shake do like I do put it
over ice stir it up and you can sip on
it for 20 minutes to an hour I'd do it
every single day I absolutely love it
you need to get back to it too it's
really good for you and it makes not fat
but it makes muscle after you workout
and you can also mix it up in a blender
with an egg and you have the most
incredible health protein shake or mix
it with a little water stir it up and
you have a little pudding and who
doesn't like pudding for more
information or to order call your
youngevity distributor today and don't
forget to ask about youngevity
home-based business opportunities
[Music]
we're back with dead donkeys no Lyman
DDS rating Network dr. Joel Wallach here
for young TV 95 per se we do have lines
open give us a call toll-free 147 nine
to five to give us toll-free one Charlie
three seven nine two five five two and
Doug let's go right back to California
and Maria okay we got rid of all the bad
stuff to maximize absorption reduce
inflammation now for atrial fibrillation
or heart palpitations or if you have
other deficiencies or you have a
circulation problem in the heart and
have clogged arteries I mean there's all
kinds of possibilities can give these
symptoms and so it 134 pounds I'd have
you take um one healthy brain and heart
pack per month one healthy brain and
heart pack per month in another bottle
of saline so you can take a total of six
a day two two and two 2 of these meal
and that's very very good for the heart
muscle and the heart blood vessels and
so forth then I also would like you to
get the ultimate daily classic tablets
ultimate daily classic champion so once
you get to bowels to those you can take
three of those twice a day that's uh me
two bottles a month and they're designed
to support healthy blood pressure but
also support healthy blood flow for the
blood vessels of the brain in the eyes
and heart and kidneys and so forth and
then I would also get a hold of me
Luca gel where'd you get two bottles of
loopy gel so you take 15 of those
capsules a day and they're designed to
support promote maybe repair of
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue here comes just between the
vertebrae and make them grow a little
bit more gain another millimeter in
thickness push the vertebrae apart take
the pressures off the roots of those
nerves that's the cars and of course you
want one bottle of MSM per month it'll
be six a day two two and two or three
and three those are big bottles again it
does the same thing when gluco gel does
but from a different direction you need
two bottles a months at the bottom in d3
so you take three of those capsules and
breakfast through their time they're
designed to support National absorption
of the calcium and other minerals and
put him in the right place you also want
to two bottles a month the destress
cancels again for the heart health and
heart function I go ahead get two
bottles of these dressed so you can take
three of those twice a day and
and they're gonna be very very good for
your heart function in case you're some
good heart failure involved there and um
let's see here let's start there and
call me every two weeks and let me know
what's going on and we'll walk you
through this okay Douglas what colors
alright let's stay in California head
over to Campbell and Lindsay you're on
with dr. Wallach Lindsay you're on the
air what you would recommend for a woman
who's got a ringworm rash and she's also
pregnant and what we can do for that
okay did this woman have any history of
asthma or bronchitis no does she have
any history of pompons constipation
diarrhea diverticulitis euroval syndrome
yeah
this ranch may be the result of gluten
this is very common where you get eczema
dermatitis psoriasis rosacea rosacea is
these rashes on the face and so we're
trying to do is have her different
gluten I mean she can eat plenty of
calories if she's pregnant right she can
have rice sweet potatoes but give up
wheat barley and oats make sure she's
taking the 90 essential nutrients how
much does she weigh Lindsay about a
hundred and twenty pounds and I will say
she is already gluten free okay good
well there may be some cross
contamination in the household from dog
food cat food spouse partner
mother-in-law kids now sneak eating
bagels for breakfast or or breakfast
cereals and things like that she's doing
the laundry so she's getting
cross-contaminated I've been handling
this stuff and her clothes are being
washed in the same laundry and so forth
and so if you're living in a house a lot
of other individuals their four-legged
critters are two-legged critters a
greeting gluten you can be obsessive
about avoiding gluten but you're going
to be in contact with it because of
cross-contamination so she needs to kind
of look at that and make sure she's not
getting cross contaminate because that
rash could be and of course she has
active
issues going on she'll pass that on to
the baby and so she got to be careful in
breastfeeding because these babies will
get asthma and bronchitis and diarrhea
and scream with pain because the fathers
are bellies and everything you know
these colicky babies are due to gluten
problems and so she needs to look at all
that but she needs to take the 90
essential nutrients how far along is she
in the pregnancy Dino
very early I think the first trimester
yeah okay well the first trimester and
the babies forming and if you're not
able to absorb efficiently it can be
problematic for the embryo and you know
they can be born with various birth
defects and all kinds of stuff and so
it's really imperative she stays away
from the gluten and takes you know the
90 cents of nutrients according to body
weight and you know answer about these
things didn't call us back and give us
some feedback and we'll walk your girls
through that's been and I'm concerned
with the gluten shoe okay all right
let's see here Douglas colors all right
let's head to st. Croix in Judea you're
on with dr. Wallach you're on the year
hello yes how can we help you
I wanted the accident question if you
ever heard that anybody became blind
from activeness
boy okay well there's people who get
blind from the optic nerve being a
squeeze how old is this person not the
optic nerve active CT IV thank you yeah
okay yeah okay how old is this person
that's me
I've been calling quite a widely I don't
I don't know I don't know that how are
you before okay okay how tall are you
and how much you weigh I weigh 170 -
okay how tall are you
five four okay now you're a little
overweight there five four it like you
see it wait one 30 maybe 35 40 pounds we
need to deal with you ever get any
ringing in the ears you know kind of a
tone called tinnitus anything like that
yeah okay you ever get any dizziness
it's called vertigo or may your disease
or Wallach swear to go where you feel
like you're seasick you have to hold on
to something you just have a balance
problem yeah okay I'm getting a hundred
percent here kiddo
yeah you have osteoporosis of the skull
and you may have optic nerve atrophy oh
and a pretty nerve atrophy when that
happens the optic nerve is formed in the
brain goes through the skull to the back
of the eye and there's a blood vessel
that goes through there another TBI and
so two things can be happening you lost
you posters go we already have the two
branches is an eighth cranial nerve the
auditory branch and a scanner causes
that innate tinnitus that tone and then
when you have the vestibular branch of
the extremal are being squeezed you get
this balance problem called vertigo why
likes vertigo or my ears disease and
then when the skull squeezes the optic
nerves it goes from the bank brain
through the skull through a tunnel to
the back of the eye when you have
osteoporosis of the skull the the bone
matrix the kind of rebar stuff of the
bones all those bleeding skull gets
thicker because of losing minerals and
wants to try and maintain strength okay
and anatomy and that those tunnels get
filled up with this connective tissue
and that's what's squeezing the H
cranial nerves are hearing the tone
you're getting balance problems and I
would bet that this oh and a optic nerve
atrophy is what's happening here that
can happen in one eye having both eyes
and so you may have other issues you
ever get hiccups or coughing no well but
does that mean a little bit yeah you
said not you didn't say no definitely no
but you said not often which means
sometimes yeah
okay do you ever have Bell's palsy or
one side of your face troops or a corner
of your mouth or one eyelid droops
yeah yeah and doctors can mistake that
for a stroke but that's the 7th grade or
the facial nerve being squeezed is it
comes through the skull and have us you
close to the skull so um hang on we'll
be back with you and I'll give you a
program after these messages you're
listening to dead doctors don't lie on
the CBS radio network with your host dr.
Joel Wallach
[Music]
imagine a rich decadent chocolate that's
actually good for you
youngevity x' triple treat chocolate is
just that an antioxidant rich dark
chocolate complete with probiotics to
aid in proper digestion this all-natural
product contains no preservatives and
for those with dietary restrictions its
gluten-free dairy-free glycemic friendly
and kosher certified not only does
triple treat dark chocolate tastes
fantastic
it contains super antioxidant
blueberries to absorb free radicals with
an ORAC value of sixteen thousand nine
hundred and thirty six per piece triple
treat chocolate also contains a
proprietary blend of probiotics with
over 500 million live healthy bacteria
per eight grams at the time of
manufacture with 80 percent reaching the
intestines which is much more than most
live culture yogurts if you'd like to
learn more about nutritional
supplementation call your local
youngevity associate and don't forget to
ask about home-based business
opportunities if you're the type of
person who likes to volunteer and help
others this should interest you what
better way to help people than to help
them with improved health youngevity has
been helping people promote optimal
health among others for decades our
approach to health is drastically
different than medical doctors who
mostly only treat symptoms as a
veterinarian dr. Joel Wallach discovered
that many common disease states are
actually preventable and reversible our
mission is to help people achieve
overall health and wellness and to help
educate others to achieve optimal
wellness as well and here's the best
part while helping people with their
health and wellness you'll also be able
to build your very own home-based
business more information contact your
local youngevity associate and don't
forget to ask about the home-based
business opportunity you've listed a
physician and veterinarian dr. Joel
Wallach helped many people on the dead
doctors dov'è talk radio program you've
also heard hundreds of people tell how
dr. Wallach and youngevity
products have changed their lives if
you're now convinced that dr. Wallach is
onto something and you want to try your
Japanese premium quality products for
yourself we could connect you with a
distributor that serves your local area
simply call our special helpline
voicemail at three one three four four
four 3463 that's three one three four
four four three four six three call
right now and leave your name telephone
number or email address and we'll see to
it that the right person contacts you
shortly
remember the phone number three one
three four four four 3463 that's three
one three four four four three four six
three call down to change your life
that's three one three four four four
3463 we're back with dead doctors don't
line the CBS Radio Network I like your
feeling to be nice like you're safe and
Doug we're going right back to st. Croix
in Judea okay for hurt issues there I
see a blindness okay which I believe is
squeezing of the optic nerve optic nerve
atrophy
she's got tinnitus ringing in ears she
got balance problem with a wall expert
ago I'm here disease all of which are
causing squeezing of these cranial
nerves by the by the osteoporosis 172
pounds Judea you need to take two
healthy panting hard packs a month to
healthy brain and heart pax romana to
full dose everything twice a day I would
also get the vitamin d3 take three of
those twenties today that's two bottles
a lot of people say well she looks like
an island
okay well that's people in the islands
in the shade okay only mad dogs and
Englishmen Guam the noonday Sun okay so
three five and D three capsules twice a
day okay then she's gonna need the gluco
gel in order to take the two large
bottles of gluco gel so she can take 15
a day five with each meal 5 at breakfast
lunch and dinner and they're designed to
support remote Manger pair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connected tissue discs
which made a vertebrae here comes bone
matrix bone itself and then she needs
two bottles of MSM so she can take nine
of those a day three at practice three
at lunch recenter time
again they're designed to support and
promote Maine's repair cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
disks between a verb a bone makes phone
and cell a different from a different
angle than the gluco gel alright and
let's see here
she also should take the ultimate daily
classic tablets to those bottles for
months or some take three twice a day
and they're gonna support healthy blood
pressure and also support healthy blood
flow through blocked arteries including
a little artery in the optic nerve is
being squeezed too closely oh and a
optic nerve atrophy all right Doug let's
go to colors all right let's head to
Santa Cruz California and Richard you're
on with dr. Wallach okay Richard I only
have a few moments sir so we need to get
right to it
yeah 72 years old i was 5-9 I'm down to
five seven my weight was up at close to
200 down to 164 with a ketosis diet I do
have to go to a doctor occasionally and
they're very concerned about my
triglycerides and all the rest of that
so I'm curious to know what I what kind
of a diet would you recommend I'm
willing to blow the doctors off but I
want to make sure that I'm handling well
Craig this rise are usually caused by
deliver getting too much sugar soft
drinks and juices and jellies and cakes
and pies and that kind of stuff okay and
so you gotta get rid of all that sugar
then I would get on 164 pounds I'll get
on to healthy brain and heart attacks or
month is our biggest hammer and toolbox
okay and I would also get the D stress
capsules away two of the healthy brain
and heart packs can take a full dose
running twice a day then get to balance
a month of the of the destress capsules
which is good for metabolism of the
liver metabolism in the brain and take 3
of those 20 a day and then it would also
use the rebound and our coffee our JAMA
Fit coffee for drinking okay
it's coffee again without sugar and
cream added to it is great for and
helping it lose weight and keep the
triglycerides down and of course the
rebound is our sports drink has 100
nutrients in it and
I get excited about that that'll help
you there but you need to stay away from
the fried foods the process meats the
oils the glutens wheat barley rye oats
and sure almost every couple of weeks at
five seven one sixty four is about right
okay
you have lost two inches in height
that's usually the disc wouldn't hurt to
throw in the gluco gel 15 of those a day
five five and five two large files a
month the MSM two vials announcing take
nine of those a day three with each meal
and then you also want to get the
vitamin D sure you get two bottles a
month I'm freezing take three of those
twice a day and that'll help absorb
calcium other minerals the fact that
you're losing two inches in height as
you put pressure on on spinal nerves get
sciatica you can get scoliosis you can
certainly get conscious stuff going on
with your heart a pH or fibrillation and
so on and so our goal here is to help
you rebuild your discs and regain that
two inches you lost and please do call
us every couple of weeks give us report
anytime you go to the doctor and he
gives you a report or status evaluation
give us a call and let us know we'll
walk through this with you we really
deal with a lot of people with these
issues you know so thank you so much for
sure thank you thank you char and thank
you Doug and Sam god bless each and
every one of you god bless her troops
god bless our Navy SEALs and god bless
america
[Music]